vous êtes dedans.
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les pôles : des territoires
extrêmes qui ne ressemblent
à rien d'autre sur terre.
MARIO CYR, directeur photo et
explorateur des fonds marins
- Chaque fois que j'y vais,
j'en reste encore un peu plus
imprégné. C'est un endroit
que j'adore, que j'ai appris
énormément, autant par la beauté
de la nature, la beauté des
animaux, mais aussi la beauté
humaine, donc les Inuits
qui vivent là-bas.
- Le parcours immersif
nous permet d'accompagner
l'aventurier et photographe
animalier dans ses expéditions
en ces terres d'extrêmes.
- C'est certain que quand on est
dans l'Arctique, ça veut dire :
bon, les grosses tempêtes,
la glace qui... Je suis déjà
parti trois jours à la dérive
sur un morceau de glace.
On est venu me récupérer
en petit avion.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les écrans géants,
la scénographie et la musique
de Jean-Michel Blais contribuent
à nous dépayser en nous
immergeant dans les pôles.
BENOIT LANDRY, co-directeur
artistique et dir. de création
- On avait du matériel
extraordinaire entre les mains,
les images que Mario a faites,
et c'était de trouver comment
les organiser pour raconter
quelque chose qui allait
à la fois nous faire voyager,
nous faire rêver,
nous transmettre l'immensité
de ces paysages-là.
- Mario Cyr a plongé plus
de 12 000 fois dans ces eaux
glacées, entouré de bêtes
qu'on dirait venues
d'une autre planète.
- Ce que moi j'aimerais essayer
de faire comprendre aux gens
ici, c'est que quand on regarde
de la glace, les gens pensent
souvent que c'est comme un
plancher vide, il y a absolument
rien en-dessous et c'est
l'endroit dans le monde
où il y a probablement
le plus de biodiversité.
- Un territoire extrême où
le danger est omniprésent,
mais aussi un territoire
fragile.
LILLI MARCOTTE, réalisatrice,
co-dir. art. et co-scénariste
- On voulait tellement pas être
moralisateurs, tellement pas
être dramatiques, étant donné
tout ce qu'on a vécu avec
la pandémie. On voulait donner
du beau à voir, un sentiment
d'aimer quelque chose, et quand
on tombe en amour avec une image
ou un décor, bien on a envie
de le protéger.
- Pas de cirque, dans cette
nouvelle production d'Éloize,
mais la même volonté de
surprendre et d'émerveiller.
Sous les glaces avec Mario Cyr,
c'est une plongée vers
l'inconnu, un voyage
vers une terre glaciale,
mais d